hello see i'm sarah juan i'm the
executive director of community youth
center and i'm also the co-chair of the
api council
and i would also like to welcome
everyone from our council to our annual
api council roundtable in a time since
our last convening api council has grown
to 57
nonprofits and cbo now our work
collectively in recent years has been
instrumental in advocating
and serving our community in so many
ways on the heels of completing our
census
efforts and in the midst of pivoting our
services and programming
to best fit the needs of those affected
by cobit
we all have had much to do in our
respective communities
our work in the depths of the pandemic
was sometimes our clients only human
interaction
every week as they await the grocery
delivery
every day as they await for their meals
delivery
we provided the necessary updated
information our committee needed
in language when they did not know where
to turn
and in a week about violence that had
black our city
we have been the fierce advocates and
allies
to secure wraparound services so in many
ways
this annual convening for api council
members with our esteemed speaker policy
is a celebration
of all we have done and continue to do
and much of this work by the way
going on behind the scenes with very
little fanfare
and no press coverage but we all know
too well the importance of our advocacy
on behalf of those we serve whether it
be addressing
food insecurity or hosting new programs
violence intervention or funds for
victims or survivors
we know that this service a matter of
life or that for many
so as you continue this work know that
you have your colleagues at api council
to lean on and ask for support and today
we truly look forward to a productive
conversation
and i thank everyone again for coming
and my great pleasure to pass it on to
our api council director kelly
thank you sarah for your welcoming
remarks and thank you to our members who
have joined us today
i would like to introduce today's panel
with our syrian community members
sarah that you just met dean edo taylor
from api legal outreach
annie chung self-help from the elderly
john osaki japanese community youth
center malcolm young
chinatown community development center
eddie on
brightline defense project luisa antonio
bayhawn equity center and our moderator
for today
gordon shin this year's roundtable is
convened under
extraordinary circumstances not only are
we still recovering from a pandemic that
has shifted
our very way of life we also still
recover
every day from the verbal physical and
emotional traumas
undergone by our community in the past
year we have shouldered so much
and there is no doubt that there is so
much we must continue to do
and indeed within these ranks as a
council we are the very community
leaders who are driving a national
movement
and our next guest has consistently been
our partner in advocacy
and has a track record of leadership
herself for over three decades
speaker nancy pelosi has championed
california's 12th district
now in our third term as speaker the
work ahead not just for our city but
this nation
has proven challenging in the wake of
our former president
in speaker pelosi we've had an ally to
denounce the very divisive
and racist language that has punctured
this era of turmoil
we've had a representative in the
capital to demand that issues of
everyday americans are prioritized
issues like food insecurity
housing and security immigration health
care
access to affordable education and
access to jobs
these are the same issues that our
community faces
every day and we continue to be grateful
for having a champion
to uplift these issues welcome speaker
pelosi
oh thank you so much thank you very much
to county thank you and thanks sarah
for bringing us together today i feel
very at home
with so many of you because we've worked
together annie chung
for decades uh gordon chen it seems like
forever
and it's wonderful that you'll be
leading our conversation today gordon
but to each and every one of you
thank you for your service to the
community as i say of san francisco the
beauty is in the mix
i always say to my colleagues i feel
sorry for you because you do not have
the vibrant aapi community
that i have in san francisco and in the
bay area and in our great state of
california
uh that makes us so special we come at
cali mentioned an array of concerns that
have brought us together
challenges that we have faced over time
little did we know we would be facing
what we have now
uh because of what has happened over the
past year and how
certain person in our country is
characterized a pandemic
unfairly and unnecessarily and
dangerously
so this is a special time usually we
meet in may and hopefully we will
again in may uh but i thought it was
important for us to
meet even sooner so we can share some
ideas
about what's happening in congress in
terms of aapi
assaults on the community which are
assaults on our democracy
this is not just about the aapi
community as
significant as that is but it challenges
our conscience it pushes us back to
think that this would happen
in our country i'm so proud of joe biden
who really wanted
within 24 hours of his inauguration was
speaking out against his giving
direction
to the justice department even before we
had an attorney general
as to what a priority this would be uh
i'm proud of our members of congress
judy chu the chair of
our our congressional asia pacific
islander
american islander community and uh
grace mang and and doris matsui the list
goes on i was telling my staff earlier
that
i have a weekly meeting it's called
crescendo and it's the heads of each of
the caucuses in the congress so it's not
many it's like about nine
people and of that nine people six
five of them are well it's you be the
judges judy chu
obviously okay it's a
head of the progressive caucus it's mark
takano head of the
um equality conference it's
stephanie murphy the head of the the
blue dog
it's ted liu the head of the of the
message group that we have that it's
it's part of that
discussion and they're like three other
razbas
i of course consider myself part of the
community since i represent one of the
most
blessed ones in the country but it it
when this so this subject has been in
the forefront
every uh every day and certainly every
week when we have the meeting to
take a tally of how far we've come or
how far we have to go
on this subject again in the course of
all of this
we've had the recovery you know the
rescue package
uh which knowing of the entrepreneurial
spirit in the aapi
community the small business initiatives
very
important we pass the violence against
women act
and and the president has funding for
that which i know is important
to the community and interacts with the
um
and i was very proud of our senator
dianne feinstein
about almost two weeks ago two from
not this past friday but the one before
after what happened in georgia
she came forth she had been sort of a
sort of a traditional supporter of the
filibuster
but after georgia she came forward and
she said
this is about what my public service is
about
the aapi community gun violence
violence against women and so i think
that we should make an
adjustment to the filibuster act so that
we can get
gun safety and these other initiatives
passed
which go to the heart of our
constitution the heart of our nation
so i was very proud of her that she
opened up to that because
that's a path even to hr1 cleaner
government
to um stop them from all the voter
suppression
that they're uh that they're trying to
do so
and they we're very proud of
working with the president uh the rescue
package it basically
is our heroes act that we passed
last may we passed some of it in
december
the rest of it in the rescue package
except
enriched invigorated with the vaccine we
didn't have a vaccine last may
we didn't have a democratic president we
had a president then who would not let
us address in any of the legislation
in an important way the disparities that
existed in our health care system and in
how we addressed the pandemic in fact he
was inflaming
the pandemic issue but he's gone forget
him right now we're going
forward with what we have to do not only
in the rescue but in the recovery which
the president just
spoke to i don't know if you saw it but
the real
they're all admit you know i say it's in
a tradition of america it's a big claim
it's transformational it involves
everyone
that everyone can participate and it
recognizes
that we are a part of families and that
if we're going to have
people in the workplace we have to make
sure the home front
is safe for them whether it's children
or older
parent or person with disabilities
that there has to be a recognition of
the role that home health care
or home care persons play it recognizes
and
we'll have another bill after this we
need two weeks he'll make another
announcement about
child care and education all of that
that are about the human
infrastructure so we're in a good place
but we're not in a good place unless we
stop
the hate crime now what we talk about
you know we have the covert hate crimes
bill that grace name is putting forth
we're proud of her work as i've said
also
tammy duckworth and maisie hirano have
been very
important in all this but doris and that
still just lives all of our hearts
telling the story that she was born
in a camp while thousands and thousands
and thousands of
uh asian americans were fighting the war
to protect the freedoms in our country
that their people didn't even have
because they were taken to camps
that's where she was born tells uh tells
that story so
in congress we have a very active and
proud
uh aapi uh
group of men who are in the leadership
every way
and respect it in every way but again
and everything we've been doing on koben
whether it's small business whether it's
access to
testing tracing treating whether it's
access to vaccines we wanted it all to
be in a way
that had equity about it i really would
like to hear
what you all have to say because it's
been a pretty eventful time with a lot
of
legislation out there that relates to
immigration
health care jobs small business in the
west
so but i'm talking with great pride
about our aapi members and
the president of the united states and
even the vice president asian american
vice president of the united states
pretty exciting
time gordon i know you're going to lead
the way for us as you have done for me
for
decades now my dear friend he has been a
hero
in housing and so many other other
issues and i said of annie annie when
did i meet you like in the 70s or
something like that you were a little
girl but
you are here we are
[Laughter]
self-help for the elderly so thank you
all very much for the opportunity for me
to hear from you
and share some of the source of pride
that i have in our aapi
let me just say this one more thing
because you know
i've taken their b you know when i went
to chinatown right at the beginning of
this and they said i was dancing in the
streets and this and that no
i'm just paying my respects and i knew
that there was any community that was
going to take this seriously a model to
the rest of the country it would be
our ahpi community in san francisco
at the same time as the president was
trying to
point figures the fingers aside and
blame and all the rest of that
uh but over and over and over again
oppressor said
that wasn't true but you know but he
said that wasn't about
dancing in the streets because there was
a pandemic it was paying respects
because of the history of respect that i
have for the community
but that i thank you for the opportunity
to share some thoughts but i want to
hear yours
so i will yield back
thank you nancy uh let me add my thanks
for you uh your leadership for our
community our city
indeed our country and i am honored
again to
moderate uh this panel there's no
shortage of questions
that our members have come up with
before
so we're going to kick it off with uh de
nito taylor
uh to talk to ask about the covet 19
hate act that you referenced earlier
dean thank you speaker speaker pelosi
for your years of leadership
and commitment to racial and social
justice
uh not only for apis but all communities
of color
um you are a rare and essential ally of
all of our communities especially in the
bay area
and i wanted to mention that you know a
lot of of your
co-uh representatives have no idea
what it's like to have an asian
community in their districts
and yet we have folks throughout the
country that are fearful
from this violence and they have no
allies locally
so we hope that you can carry that
message that the api community in
america is not invisible
we're in every state and there our
concerns need to be
taken to the highest level of priorities
uh even if we don't make up a huge
percentage of the electorate so we'd
like to
ask you for maybe a status update on the
covet 19
uh hate act that maisie and uh
representative ming are are kind of
championing
uh apparently this will lead to
multilingual
access to uh helplines or perhaps the
department of justice being involved
with
uh with local crimes um could you give
us a
your your take on that well thank you
thank you for your kind words and
recognition uh that i'm very blessed
but not everyone is so blessed they they
are
the community exists there they just
don't realize it
as fully as they should or choose to
recognize it
so here's the thing when the coba 19
hate act sponsored by maisie
senator maisie hirano and congresswoman
grace ming
grace ning is a leader in the congo
she's the chair of
one of our committees that determines
how we function there
she just presented a few days ago about
uh some things so she commands a great
deal of respect when she speaks people
listen
she almost cried though when we had the
hearing last week i mean
it i don't even want to talk about it
because i don't want you to even be
aware of how ridiculous
some of the members are and how
oblivious they are to a sense of decency
about what america is
and how blessed we are with our aapi
community
okay so on if we go back april 12th
uh we go back on april 14th
the judiciary committee will mark up the
the bill the kova 19 hate act
uh it will come to the floor in may
uh we have this is pretty fast for
legislation
when we have a whole backlog of things
that uh we need to do um
regarding the pandemic and rest but
we're giving it priority and moving it
forward
the recognition that you've been just
since um
march 2022 and that year's over three
thousand it's almost like ten
hate crimes a day against the api
community that
we know about that we know about it may
be much more
um uh judy chu maisie and tammy
dockworth as well as grace have been
in the lead on on making sure that
everybody
is fully attuned to what is happening
uh as i've said before though we are
very pleased that on
on the first day of office the president
condemned
uh attacks and martial federal resources
to combat them
the attorney general shall explore
opportunities to support
consistent with uh actual laws this
efforts of state and local agencies
as well as aapi communities and
community-based organizations to prevent
discrimination
bullying harassment and hate crimes
against api individuals and to expand
the collection of data now that's really
important
let me just tell you from my experience
on hate crimes in general whether it's
against lgbtq
or aapi or whatever what is important
is that we can document
what happened and what i said to my
colleagues in my
beautiful experience for me to be in
chinatown the rest some of the older
people my age they you know they get
assaulted but they don't they're not
familiar nor would i be
even if i were not you know my first
language were not chinese
they don't get the language these crude
people are using somebody has to write
it down
so it is a testimony to the fact
that this was a hate crime it wasn't
just i'm going to steal her purse or i
don't like this
or this is that it's a hate crime
so again a lot of it is language because
and when i say language i don't mean
chinese to english or
tagalog to english or anything like that
i'm just talking about
generational generational what
what does that mean what he said or
something so to the extent
that if somebody sees something like
this they must listen
at the same time what the person says
you don't belong here go back to where
you belong you know all that
really vile stuff but if we can have
that
that helps us to collect the data
and again we have to shall we say i've
always been frustrated with how you have
to have that evidence
when it's so clearly self-evident
but in any event may
april 14th for the markup made for the
legislation and we want to give it a big
you know awareness as far as the public
is concerned
you better not think about doing this
isn't it a shame
isn't it thank you nancy we'll be there
donald speaker our next question is from
malcolm
young of the chinatown community
development center
and he wants to ask about affordable
housing
malcolm uh well first of all thank you
again
uh for spending this time with us madam
speaker
unlike gordon i'm not allowed to call
you nancy so we'll stick with madam
speaker
oh we haven't earned that right yet i'll
call you
i'll do that well in that case
um and and nancy
i also just wanted to thank you again
for coming to chinatown last year
um uh it it it was
um a show of respect we felt that
respect
and i just want to deeply deeply thank
you for that and
um along with annie uh and maybe a
couple of others here
we had the privilege of walking
chinatown with you and and
the community felt that so thank you so
much don't forget our delicious lunch
that's right at the dim sum corner that
was
that was that was very good um
that's right and they're still there so
they're still there they're still open
they're still trying to survive
um so we encourage anybody and everybody
to come visit chinatown just like you
did last year so thank you so much
from that i can't wait to come back
um in terms of affordable housing um you
know this is a issue that's
been critical for the api community for
really as long as any of us can remember
places like chinatown are surrounded by
areas that are wealthier and which
have always been a threat to take over
chinatown and convert it into
something that doesn't resemble the
community we have and
so affordable housing the residential
component of chinatown is something that
we've always paid very close attention
to
um coming out of the last recession
um we we saw that the recovery um was
uneven in many ways
and housing impact in particular was
uneven
uh in san francisco unfortunately um it
led to
a significant amount of displacement and
pain
frankly for our tenants across the city
but particularly low income
seniors immigrants and people of color
so affordable housing and affordability
is something that
i know that we're eager to keep an eye
on coming out of this
recession which i'm optimistic that
we're going to
um so my question around this and it may
have been part been answered earlier
today but i'm going to pose it anyway
what is congress and the white house
doing uh to advance fair and affordable
housing
and i think the second part is is really
critical
as well and and to stop evictions um
both in san francisco
uh and across the united states well
thank you malcolm for your question
you have on this call real hero on
housing affordable housing and our
country gordon chin i've seen him
recognize nationally in washington d.c
locally and personally in every way so
he
he's our leader and a go-to person on
this subject
currently and correct me i mean gordon
um
elaborate further if you would
in the uh recover in the i keep saying
recovery but the recovery's next
in the rescue plan uh we had uh 27.5
billion dollars in rental assistance
this is the work of maxine waters the
chair of the
financial services committee and as as
gordon knows it's
it's financial services banking and
housing and urban development so how's
an important part of that
and then a homeowner system 10 billion
dollars to states territories and tribes
to try to help some of the homeowners
because
sometimes the renter is you know it's
like
two or three unit place but if the
renter can't pay
then the homeowner the owner can't pay
the bank
so it has a couple different ways to be
helpful president himself though
has extended the eviction moratorium to
the end of june
so that's an improvement so this gives
this system a chance
uh to to work it's also five billion
dollars for homeless and
other things but that is the rescue
and the rescue was coronavirus centric
and so
we need to do much more than that so in
our next plant which is
what the president announced today
it has a lot in it but among those
things
is that housing when we talk about
infrastructure people think roads
bridges
mass transit but this is about
infrastructure water broadband
housing education and the housing piece
would probably be
two-fold one affordable housing
and public housing public housing
is an important part of it some public
housing needs to be rehabbed some of it
needs to be replaced
but also making the stock of good
housing whether it's public or
affordable
that will be part of that legislation
and maxine has that as a very
high priority in terms of how to do it
but the president has it as a priority
in his proposal as well
i worked with gordon because when i
first went to congress my first
committee assignment i had was the
housing committee because this has
always been a challenge for san
francisco we have the very wealthy and
we have
the need for affordable stock and we
don't need the gentrification
to accommodate the hands habs to
undermine the beautiful diversity of our
community so let's stay in close touch
on that to make sure
that as they some of the money will go
to states to localities
to community-based organizations let's
make sure
it reaches how we need it to reach to
sustain the beautiful diversity of our
communities
thank you madam speaker thank you our
next question will come from annie chung
uh about immigration ready
hi annie any your mute
i thought that it was automatic sorry
nancy really thank you for this
opportunity for us to express to you
what are some of the challenges and
priorities that our community are facing
on the area of immigration will i see a
lot of positive
really signs ever since president biden
stepped
in there were some really mean
regulations that the former
administration was trying to pass but i
think that
uh one by one they've kind of been
rescinded or addressed so thank you very
much for your advocacy on that
but can you share with us a little bit
more details about president biden's
comprehensive immigration
reform because we we hear something
about it but we're not sure
what the timeline is and i know that
congress is working on legislations
regarding
our daca program our dreamers program
and also
uh the temporary uh
protected service right the dps and the
uh
enforced departures all those
legislations are really important to the
aapi community
so we'd like to learn a little bit more
and
how how can we how can we help yeah
thank you annie for your service in so
many ways it's self-help for the elderly
whether it's healthcare or any subject
that relates to them
and this important issue of immigration
i remember when we were sitting on the
floor
crying when they passed the um was that
thing so-called welfare reform bill that
was so damaging
too many of the people that we were
trying to help on top of
some of the immigration matter uh it was
it's heartbreaking to see how public
policy which
supposedly has a big vision but has a
terrible
impact on individuals so in this bill
uh well first of all thank you for
acknowledging what we're trying to do
the dream act and the for the daca
and the or the dreamers even more than
daca and then the
temporary protected status we passed
that legislation in the house a couple
of weeks ago
and we also passed the farm worker
modernization act which
is important in california in terms of
farm workers in the rest but across the
country
the uh it's interesting to note i didn't
know this
until recently i did stand on the floor
for over eight
hours uh speaking about the dreamers act
it was the longest speech in the history
of the congress
it wasn't really a speech people were
handing me stories
of dreamers in their districts and then
it was coming over for the senate so i
just could
be telling stories but the minute you
give up the floor
it's over so you can't you can't give up
the floor so that way that's
what that was but anyway just to say
what a priority that is
for our congress and verse as obviously
for me as speaker
the um i didn't know until recently
though that the first
applicants for bajaka were korean
americans
but koreans so what we do know
is that the dreamers are multi
represent the beautiful diversity of our
country people think of them mostly
uh from latin america but it from africa
from
from asia you know the beautiful
diversity of the aapi community
and that is reflected in many of the
dreamers as well
in our country so we're hoping that we
can pass that
in the senate and i'll go to that in a
moment as well as the farmworker one
that has strong republican support
we've got eight or nine votes for the
dreamers in
in the house these friends these people
are not necessarily sharing our values
all the way we can only get eight or
nine to vote for that
uh on the comprehensive bill of this is
a bigger deal
while if we could pass dreamers and
workforce and
tps the temporary protective status that
you imagine
and put them on a path of citizenship
it's millions of people
it's millions of people it's more than
half of the
those who were not fully documented in
the country now
so we're hoping we can get that done but
at the same time
everybody knows we have to have
comprehensive immigration reform
uh it's possible it there was a
bipartisan bill in the senate a few
years ago
but we were not in control in the house
and the republican speaker would not
bring it to the floor
we're not bringing it to the floor so
again we want to try to get to that
bipartisan place and here's what it does
that is a
special interest in a fight that we
always make
for the um community and it has a path
to citizenship to help nearly
four million people who have approved
approved sponsored petitions who are
waiting for a visa
some up to 20 years many in the aapi
community
it ref uh it has includes the
family-based immigration clears
backlogs recaptures unused visas
this uh eliminates long wait lines
increased prairie country visa caps
eliminate the 10-year bar allows
immigration with approved family
sponsored petition
to join family in the u.s temporarily
with work authorization while waiting
uh for the green card and embraces
diversity and all this
but as you know one of the big
priorities for the aapi community
was family unification and that is
something that we think has to be
in the comprehensive immigration reform
so let's stay in touch
i know as i've said to my colleagues
i've learned more from the
chinese chinese-american community about
naturalization
because you've been our teachers and our
mentors
on that subject and now to the entire
aapi
community so thank you for your
leadership there when
we i mean we think we should be able to
get the other two
passed in the senate again we're talking
about the filibuster
they're talking about that filibuster if
we could get some relaxation about the
filibuster
then we think now we're trying
to sneak some of the options we're
trying to prioritize some of this
in a reconciliation bill
but i call it with respect but
nonetheless
in shorthand the bird lady i don't know
what she says about that but we think we
can make a case
about the budget implications of
immigration
in our country and we were going to try
to do that
but absent that let me just tell you
this
don't say i said this this is just for
us
in 2000 for some reason over time it's
come to you need 60 votes
without going into that whole history
you need 60 votes
in 2013 the democrats
under a democratic president changed it
to
51 votes for the president's nominations
to the cabinet
and some judgeships not the supreme
court
they made it 51. in 2017
the republican president who shall
remain nameless
and the republican senate who should
remain in the minority
or they changed it
to include the supreme court and that's
why we have the court we had
52 votes that's what they had 52
republicans
and that's 60 votes to put that court in
place
so we think that if it only takes 51
or 52 to name a supreme court justice
it should only take 51 or 52
to have a path to citizenship for 11
million people
in our country and that's our fight
what is it and we're we back here play
100
and our next question uh will come from
lisa antonio
uh from the binding equity center
uh and she wants to talk about child
care
luisa
hi luisa where's lisa melissa
here good afternoon madam speaker
um thank you very much for um having
this discussion and
thank you so much for being a staunch
supporter of the api community
and for uh specifically for the filipino
community
i'm glad you mentioned about you know
the path to citizenship
family reunification which
uh includes the uh filipino world war ii
veterans family reunification in that
particular
legislation and we are very pleased and
having you as a champion there
you know um we feel great about that
and we've been uh relying on you since
the 90s about the filipino veterans
on equity and you're still there for us
and we do appreciate it
uh my question is the american rescue
plan
provided critical funding through the
child care stabilization
fund and increases to ccdbg allocations
we know that this one-time lift must be
permanent
is this type of investment likely to
continue or
be rolled back to pre-pandemic levels
well thank you lisa for your work in
this regard and
yeah we've been trying a long time to
have justice for our filipino events
as you probably recall my college
roommate was filipino
uh filipina she was from the philippines
uh
um and uh so constantly reminding me
about that subject emilia lourdes
benitez was her name
amy liu we called her hanging out and
she's
back home in the philippines for now
decades but
she did visit me in the speaker's office
i um let me just say this
in terms of the child care issue thank
you for that
in our bill that we passed in the summer
which is moving america
forward we had
200 billion dollars for child care
this bill has about 45 billion dollars
it is a
39 for child care
a few billion for a head start and then
maybe like one and then another five for
another kind of
child care program but that as you say
that
that's cobit-centric for for
us to have what we need for child care
in america
for it to be transformative we really
must do much more and as i say in
january
in uh the summer at the end of june
beginning of july
we had a 200 billion dollar
plan separate from covet centric
and we had in the rescue as you know the
45 billion
the president in the next iteration of
recovery has 25 billion more
in the infrastructure bill and i think
we just keep
growing that two things that i think
have to happen in a major way that are
shall we say central to people's lives
but not always on the top big money
things in bills
one is child care this is everything
this enables women
and men to be in the workforce whether
it's a child
or senior you're caring for it's family
care of one form or another
and mental health especially after the
covid
we have to think in a bigger way about
mental health
and those two things we're trying to say
really
need a bigger uh commitment of resources
and that being financial and otherwise
and listening to the community-based
organizations who are delivering those
kinds of services so that we can
allocate the money where there's the
absorptive capacity to get the job
get the job done but thank you for your
leadership on that
so again for our members this is like
fighting words child care let me add
them
you know everybody talks about any
subject
women in the workplace women in the
academic world women in
government you have to have child care
and you have to know
if you're if i'm going to hire somebody
say i'm a guy and i'm going to hire
somebody
i want to know that that person man or
woman
is fully at work when they're at work
and they're not thinking oh my god
i don't even trust the child care that
my child is in
you know it has to be that level of
quality
and trust so that women
largely women can take their full place
in a
in our economy and our country and be
providers
for their families amassing resources
they need for their retirement
meeting the needs of their families
multigenerationally
thank you nancy i think we have time to
slip in one more quick question and this
is from john osaki
john hi john hello speaker pelosi
uh so i want to say that this is my 25th
year
as executive director and i've never
called you nancy
i'm going to consider myself part of the
club that's graduated
the very special club to be able to call
you man but
thank you very much for joining us here
today and um
you know what i wanted to ask about is
um you know an article came out in time
magazine yesterday
about why the children of this country
are not
taught asian american history and
specifically
about why they are not taught about the
racism
that asian american communities have
experienced and you know my
the you might recall that in 1988 the
civil liberties act
that provided reparations for my mother
and father who were both
incarcerated during the war also had an
education fund
and that education fund was
unfortunately dramatically
underfunded by the time allocations were
made
and today we have the japanese american
confinement site program
um which is providing you know really
critical education
about the japanese american
incarceration and i think the federal
government
has a really important role to play
in educating this country and the
american public
about the asian american community about
the racism that we've experienced
not just for the japanese american
community but for all asian american
communities so
i would certainly like to see programs
like the
japanese american confinement site
program elevated
in profile provided more resources and
for other communities
to have programs similar where they can
develop
educational projects and ways to
inform the american public about all the
different experiences
of asian american communities in this
country so that was that is something
obviously because of your long time
support of our community your
familiarity with all of us
you know that is something that we would
certainly very much appreciate you
you know taking a leadership role and
making sure that the federal government
takes responsibility for making sure
that this country is educated
about not only our contributions to
you know american society but you know
really all the past
um harm and racism that we faced as
communities
well thank you john for that question
uh let me just say that it's always
interesting to me
when we talk about the greatness of
america
we say abraham lincoln during the civil
war
he built the trans trans-continental
railroad no
he didn't chinese americans military
continent
so let's make sure that that
contribution and as you look at the
pictures
of actually the people who did the job
you got like seven white guys standing
there
slightly acknowledging who really built
the railroad and when i say built i'm
not just talking
about the physical labor which would be
significant enough
but the intellectual resource that it
took
to build and have it come together where
it was supposed to come together so that
would be one thing
but in terms of the um uh reparations
the rest i happened to be in congress
and voted for that legislation
and education was supposed to be an
important part of that
and i think now well i think we're
embarrassed
i think america is embarrassed by what
happened during world war ii
as i said earlier doris metsu we talked
about being built
born in a camp and and
we know that that um
while people were being sent to camps
tens of thousands of asian america aapi
were fighting the war for our country a
country's freedom
being deprived to their own families and
relatives
in the united states so i think that
that i think we've grown up
a bit and that there should be more
facing the reality of our history at
that time
and so uh doris well of course
i served with bob matsuya who also was
born there
uh minetta you know we had a rich
history
serving with them at the time of that
legislation
doris has congresswoman atsui has a bill
to reauthorize the funds and add a new
two million dollars a year grant fund
um and it's included in my own
appropriations request
uh for that money now in terms of
the national park service i mean this
is an um an interpretation
that is so valuable to the american
people
and and i think that they are ready to
embrace a full
for a fuller embrace of showing off the
camps
they look all nice and neat of course
and so we were like well that looks good
no it wasn't good they were incarcerated
it wouldn't it isn't good not to have
your freedom
uh no matter how nice and neat people
kept it
so we have to make sure uh that the
injustice that was so much a part of
that
is very much a part of the
interpretation
that goes forward and i'm sure that it
will but rest assured that with doris
there and mark takano
and uh and others that
strictly japanese but the others who who
are aapi
uh sharing that value we've done that
with native americans
have we have we really corrected the
record there
we've done it with the african-american
community in so many ways
what what happened with the um uh
shall we say discoverers of america and
what that meant to native americans and
the rest
we really haven't faced up to where we
are as a nation
last year uh now it's a year and a half
ago
because i don't cope with almost not
counting as a year
i took a delegation to ghana where we
saw the first
the place 400 years ago where the first
death ships took africans
as slaves to america the brutality
that all is beyond beyond
what you could imagine i mean there were
dungeons and treated
worse than animals worse than
animals and upstairs they were in church
praying
really what's the hypocrisy of that the
europeans they were praying
these are god's children that you are
mistreating and you're upstairs
praying like you're some kind of a good
person so um uh
and that to me was the beginning of a
very important part of american history
it started in africa uh the um
i think even those who were involved in
the 40s
knew that this was wrong but we just
have to teach the american people so
that nothing like that ever happens
again
and sadly this covet hate
thing uh brings back that
that terrible terrible memory so you're
absolutely right john let's stay in
touch on that it'll be
it'll be good now my doctor dr hayashi
i went to the grandfather grandfather
the son
and now i go to the grandson dentist
every time i went to the dentist when i
came to san francisco
a long time ago all before i was in
congress
i'd open my mouth and hear about
how we had to get the reparations i was
captive audience and so every time i
spoke about it on the floor
i clearly remember dr hayashi
and telling me how awful it was he must
have known that one day this mother of
five
who's in here is going to go to congress
because he was
definitely convinced that i had to leave
the office
every time fully aware of what
the injustice was and what the
possibilities were
and that's a real tribute to the
japanese-american community
and those who were able to attract to
the cause
in the community i know so many people
who
were active democrats but they
relinquished all of that to work on the
reparations
uh side of things so again thank you for
making america more american
by facing up to what we are and what we
did and what we should be doing better
and making sure that our children know
the story thank you john and
thank you nancy uh to close it out uh
for us this morning is uh steering
committee member
eddie on eddie eddie hi eddie
oh speaker pelosi and thank you again
for your leadership on these issues i
think it's just really passing the
microphone the virtual microphone back
to you on closing remarks as we've
discussed today we've seen a lot of
cross
cutting issues being discussed whether
it's housing jobs
uh welfare reform immigration reform and
we thank you for your leadership on
being able to hold this at both the
national level
and also uh be sensitive to very local
communities that are struggling right
now
and you're very aware of asian pacific
islander communities in san francisco
spanning from south the market to the
tenderloin
to chinatown and just would love for you
to
uh end us on a strong note today well
thank you
for your absolutely again what that
means in terms of
equity because that is the word
that is what we should all be striving
to whether it's equity
and access to health care affordable
housing whether it's equity in terms of
the workplace it has equity in terms
of environmental justice almost every
subject that you can name
uh there has been some injustice that
needs to be corrected
and under this president i think we will
see transformation
because it will be predicated on equity
not trickle down with look for these and
then
about starting with equity and letting
that
uh bubble up uh so uh what has
where we have been successful and lord
knows this and nanny and
is where we have worked together on
these issues
not that i come back and say oh this is
what we've picked up no
what you tell me and i take back and now
of course we have more diversity in the
congress
uh so uh so that's a blessing because
we have a place named
young moms little boys that she brings
to the floor and
it's
so for us it's frankly it's all about
the children
all of america's children and equity
for all of america's families uh whether
it's
i always say it's about the children
their health their education
education uh the economic security of
their families
for three that are addressed
in the rescue package
one further to a safe environment in
which they can thrive we pass the gun
bill
in the president's infrastructure bill
it's about clean air clean water
no lead that kind of thing so safe for
the children
and then a world of peace in which we
can they can reach their fulfillment
uh we learn a lot from you about all of
those things
so know your power in this discussion
uh because it's not for us to assume
anything it's for us to know
where you think the difference will be
made we've had some nice successes over
time with some
housing projects and what we tried to do
in
all the subjects i named health
education etc
but more needs to be done and there is
an opportunity now
with this president this president is
a tran a unifier in a unifying way
so the terms we have now is to have
people take a step
beyond this these hate crimes
and really call upon our republican
colleagues
i don't even mean this in a partisan way
except it's necessary for them
to to shed some of the things they said
in the hearings last week did you
hope you didn't see some of the things
they said
uh and just take us to a place that if
we're going to be proud to be americans
we have to be proud
of our aapi community and that is not
with any condescension but with the
greatest
respect and pride
that we take so let's stand close touch
on all the things we talked about here
and beyond uh again i feel very um
proud to represent san francisco i brag
about it all the time that
when i go home and i go to chinatown or
i go to japan town or go wherever
and i think oh those poor souls they
don't have a district like this
how boring like that must that be
how uninspiring must that be don't tell
them i said that but i do tell them
anyway
in any case thank you all very much
let's just make some measures of our
success
whether it's about how we inform the
public
our children about this part of our
country whether it's about how we expand
our
our housing whether it's about all of
the issues that we
talked about uh how we when we meet
may let's see what differences we have
made even in a matter of
six eight eight weeks okay and then what
our
goals are beyond that i then we'll be on
our way with our
infrastructure package it won't be
passed yet but we'll be marking it up in
committee
and your um voices will be important
here at that time thank you coordinator
thank you thank you nancy
you're getting your picture everybody
now
real quick we love you nancy okay
we love you nancy love you nancy
i love you nancy we joined the nancy
club
i'm going to take a quick uh screenshot
one moment
all right thank you thank you thank you
thank you everybody thank you madam
speaker
thank you kelly thanks thanks kelly
thanks gordon
you